welcome back to part 2 of nightmare
house I forgot that was gonna happen I
just want a freaking gasoline for my car
oh my god stuff everywhere
I think I know why I died though it's
supposed to jump here and then there
there Oh what the [ __ ] I can't move
oh dude
teabag teabag you are smexy lady oh I
guess friend oh oh [ __ ] [ __ ] you oh
oh I'm out of ammo oh my god there's a
wall here oh this is gonna fall
I didn't fall why are you dead bro ah
[ __ ]
she's not a problem
oh I barely saw it that was a creepy one
oh my god oh I don't want to play
anymore
[Music]
some dark
oh my god
my fun Jesus Christ great everything
thank you Oh humbug oh [ __ ]
Oh 500 [ __ ] barrels [ __ ]
oh my god gives me a [ __ ] break
Oh milk I missed you yeah I was gasps
all [ __ ] [ __ ]
over there we go
yeah
nope give it a shot give it where do
they put it I don't know everybody god
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
[ __ ]
it's a barricade top row ah shut there's
a woman oh my god die already you piece
of [ __ ]
they never [ __ ] I hide I [ __ ] ugly
face
jesus [ __ ] penis everywhere god this
[ __ ] game okay
where the heck tonight why do it are
there it is check-in give me a gun give
me five minutes
five [ __ ] minutes I thought oh my god
yeah have to complain Billie's [ __ ]
do
oh why am I still going into this
[ __ ] a man
[ __ ] you our limits our analysis of
idiots pretty obnoxious
ah how's everything Frank oh god it's so
late I shouldn't be swimming it's really
cozy
huh sup bro
come on dance with me another quarter
you drop something oh thank you pool but
I have no end
oh there it is oh my god I had a freakin
shotgun
that's a waste though some vibe I press
for like a gazillion [ __ ] whatever
it's down there I don't want to find out
let's go here our Oliver shoots so nice
me okay
so how do we do this
jump on that I like on my face turn just
like I some freaking fire topic
oh [ __ ] and don't scream okay whatever
or I could just Crouch get my space
wonder if I can jump them oh [ __ ]
oh I could jump
sweet not sweet
where's my revolver it's on 203 for one
it's to twice someone tell me please
here I'll stop winking you [ __ ]
my god this is so much better
oh my god it's like I'm playing forever
I don't want to play anymore this is
ridiculous
oh you so ugly oh my god stop doing that
you [ __ ] eyes
oh my god I hate y'all so [ __ ] much
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
I'm out of here [ __ ] you oh my god
they're [ __ ] everywhere back to the
car
[Music]
[Music]
freaking goosebumps oh my god oh my god
I haven't even started playing the
[ __ ] game
[ __ ] you I'll [ __ ] email you thank
God
it's better be [ __ ] worth it guys oh
my god yeah
ten minutes today I'm I don't really
give a [ __ ] how the [ __ ] I closed it aha
[Music]
you